*musique de zelda*
Waouh, les amis aujourd'hui est un jour spécial car je peux enfin vous parler de TOURNE LA PAGE mon livre
Merci ouah c'est original bravo c'est pas comme si tous les autres Youtubeurs l'avaient fait avant toi
En plus t'en as pas déjà sorti un, le "machinbook" ?
Alors non c'est vraiment mon premier livre j'avais par contre pu customiser dix pages d'un agenda et d'un Note Book chez Carrefour mais ça n'a rien à voir avec un livre.
Ok mais ton livre c'est toi qui l'a écrit au moins ? c'est totalement moi qu'il ai écrit mais pas seul
Je l'ai écrit avec Maxenss que vous connaissez bien maintenant, en fait après le premier livre de youtubeur en France je crois que c'était
Celui de EnjoyPhoenix tous les éditeurs m'ont contacté pour me dire "Eh viens on fait un livre tu nous donnes l'idée on fait tout pour
toi  "ARGEEEENT "  ce à quoi j'ai répondu NON
Vous savez pourquoi... j'ai trop d'ego pour ne pas écrire moi-même mon livre c'est évident donc j'attendais le bon moment j'attendais de trouver une idée qui me
plaisait en fait et ça a été le cas pour Tourne La Page dès que j'ai eu l"idée j'ai contacté Maxenss ça l'a fait kiffer et
on a écrit tout ça à deux c'était génial des bons moments "et pourquoi il s'appelle Tourne La Page ?"  c'est une référence au titre aguicheur
qu'on peut trouver un peu partout sur youtube y compris sur ma chaîne je trouvais ça marrant de mettre "tourne la page" et de
simuler un morceau de la page d'après qui dépasse où du coup tu vas t'attendre à un truc et en tournant la page euuuh
aaah je dis pas ce qui se passe je veux pas spoil. Mais du coup c'est quoi ton livre en fait ? en gros c'est une sorte de
livre interactif c'est une sorte de cahiers de vacances pour ados et jeunes adultes donc des gens comme moi et vous en gros dans le livre y a
36 idées, chaque idée est illustrée par un énoncé qui vous dit quoi faire et à côté une illustration quand je dis une illustration c'est
assez vague parfois vous allez devoir dessiner sur l'illustration vous allez devoir la découper parfois juste la lire et vous amuser si j'ai bien
fait mon travail donc ouais je pense qu'on peut mettre ça dans la catégorie "livre interactif"
slash cahier de vacances
slash livre qu'il faut acheter absolument slash pour la fin d'année
ok et qui a fait les illustrations du coup parce que si c'est toi j'achète clairement pas. Tu insinues que je dessine mal oui
tu as totalement raison rassurez-vous si j'avais fait les illus ça ressemblerait à ça
Certains ont réussi à le reconnaître sur twitter c'est le style de mon frère c'est mon frère qui a fait toutes les illustrations du livre alors
pour ceux qui savent pas mon frère dans la vie est illustrateur et c'est lui qui a fait notamment ma photo youtube ma bannière youtube et mon outro youtube
du coup vous pouvez vous faire une idée d'à quoi vont ressembler les illus mais bon dans le doute je vous en mets quand même
2, 3 par ci par là et on arrête après ça spoil un peu trop livre je suis trop
content du livre et du résultat de ce que c'est par rapport à ce que j'avais imaginé parce que c'est beaucoup mieux que ce que
j'avais imaginé grâce à mon frère qui a fait toutes les illus qui des fois validait nos idées ou des fois nous disait "oh les
mecs c'est pas ouf!" du coup grâce à lui dans le livre les meilleures idées et surtout toutes les idées sont
illustrées mais
d'une manière incroyable moi j'adore le style de mon frère et je suis objectif ou pas trop vu que c'est mon frère mais vraiment je trouve qu'il
a un talent fou donc merci Florent Hauchard d'avoir accepté de bosser sur ça avec moi je sais que ça t'a pris beaucoup de temps
que tu as dû beaucoup bosser que tu as eu des cheveux blancs mais mec
regarde le résultat putain ! Regardez on va on va l'appeler on va lui demander ce qu'il pense du livre
*sonnerie* "Allo ouais vieux tu es content du résultat du livre ?
Florent : "Très très content mec". Et ben c'est super j'étais en pleine vidéo tu viens de dire à tout le monde avec sincérité que tu l'aimais.
* Rire de Florent* "quoi ?!". Je tourne et tu viens vraiment de dire aux gens qu'il est génial c'est
naturellement c'est très bien tu dis pas ça parce que tu veux qu'il se vende pour toucher un maximum d'argent quand même ?
Florent : "bah y a un peu de ça et..."
* Rire * il est comme son frère celui là c'est incroyable
Bref pour te répondre voix off
hyper chiante c'est mon frère qui a fait les illus. Plait-il ? Non non j'ai dit voix  off très agréable ! Et on peut l'acheter où
ton livre ? Et bein partout vous pouvez le commander en ligne entre autre sur Amazon et la Fnac
et sinon il est dispo dans tous les magasins qui vendent des livres donc la fnac euh
la fnac
toutes les librairies etc !  Ok c'est juste pour dire à mes potes de ne pas l'acheter s'ils tombent dessus.
Ah !  Je l'achète pas ! Putain mais tu m'en mets plein la gueule depuis tout à l'heure ! Je l'achèterai pas euh nanananère ! (voix puérile)
Je ne l'achète pas euuuu ! Tu vas l'acheter mon livre je vais te le faire bouffer fils de pute
*bruit d'étouffement*
Il est tellement bien ce livre que même à manger ça a l'air agréable achetez TOURNE LA PAGE
Eh ben vous savez tout ! Ah !! et un dernier truc dont je veux vous parler c'est que je donne un hashtag le hashtag tourne la page
n'hésitez pas à prendre en photo les pages de votre livre où vous allez devoir dessiner et on fera une vidéo avec Maxenss dans quelques
semaines pour regarder tout ce que vous avez fait avec le livre en fait voilà c'est une petite idée qu'on a eue quitte à ce
que vous deviez dessiner des fois où créer un truc
grâce au livre bah autant qu'on voit ce que vous avez fait et ben voila ! Hésitez pas si vous l'achetez à me faire un
petit tweet pour me dire ce que vous en avez ce que vous ... *bafouille*
Oh le mec fait un livre il sait même pas parler !! Me dire ce que vous en avez pensé voilà j'ai dit tout ce que j'avais à
dire je vous remercie d'avoir pris le temps de regarder cette vidéo je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine
j'espère que ça vous plaira de tout coeur mais j'ai pas trop de doute je pense vraiment que vous allez passer un bon moment ! A bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo !  Moi je vais tourner la page mais hors caméra pour pas vous spoil
*bruit magique*  wouaw incroyable !!